you're not getting the crazy Frank today
you're getting the good one because I
just started my meds again off my meds
I'm a little out there when did you
first start taking when I was a kid so
tell me about your childhood uh my
childhood I grew up in San Diego I was
born and raised I was born in sharp Mo
hospital I was born with the cord
wrapped around my neck so I was
pronounced dead when I was born so I had
to be put in incubator and if it wasn't
my father wasn't there he was getting
high at the time I guess he showed up
later on but if it wasn't for my
grandfather um I probably wouldn't be
alive because he threatened the doctor's
life to to keep me alive so he kept me
alive and I was an incubator for a long
time and I had to have major blood
transfusions and uh a lot of things
happened when I was born to me so right
there's a miracle in my life you know um
I always look back at that and go man
you know when I get mad that I'm here I
think back at that I'm supposed to be
here you know and how I ended up here
today is uh um you know I had dreams and
I had goals in my life and I was a
motivated person my whole life you know
and I don't know
exactly how I got here to this point in
my life I'm 44 years old I shouldn't
have made it past probably 20 years old
honestly if you want to know the truth
um
I I've been a millionaire twice over
with the work that I do I've owned my
own businesses I've worked for huge
power companies that paid me god- awful
amounts of money for not doing hardly
anything which
uh has a lot to do with my mental
illness there was a lot of elect
electricity I've been electrocuted a
couple times um from high voltage um
I've been run through a rock Crusher and
almost killed twice from the electricity
and The Rock Crusher and the companies
just threw it under the table hit it and
I'm a loyal person so I never I never
sued anybody I was never a person who
wanted to Sue and and gain something
that I didn't earn right um so going
back to my
childhood I was raised in San Diego
we're Native American um we have some
Mexican in us we have Aztec blood in us
we have uh
um a lot of family members a lot of
friends that are from deep down in
Mexico um we are we are Kumi natives but
our family was kicked out of the Kumi
Mission Indian tribe so uh the Yaki
n Mission Indians picked us up from uh
Arizona New Mexico and Texas so they
recognized us as as Yaki because we were
kicked out of the Kumi for political
purposes and reasons probably for money
I would imagine right um so how I grew
up is uh I mean I remember being three
years old rid riding on an airplane up
to Sacramento my my grandparents and my
uncle worked for a company called the
company so which was always weird to me
and when they didn't have work when I
was four or five years old my Grandpa
would put me in the garage they have a
huge shop and he'd have me sand C cars
down old 54s 56s 57
Chevys bunch of gangster cars bunch of
plymouths everything you can think of so
I learned how to work on cars at a young
age you know and um at a young age my
grandfather was pretty much the the one
that was Raising Me and
uh he would take me to work with him a
lot so I learned how to do a lot of
different trades I learned how to do uh
um asphalt concrete grading Paving
everything you could think of I I
learned at a very young age so my
grandfather was pretty much my father my
father had left when I was six years old
um him and my
mother decided to get a divorce my
father is a he's on he's on the Spectrum
he's got Aspergers he was he was a
genius he built computers pretty much
before computers were even how they are
today you know he would take them apart
and put and solder everything together
the circuit boards make everything and
he num knew numbers real well you know
just like I do you know and I never
understood it until now right um but
what I remember as a child is uh um I
remember being around my father and and
watching him do drugs with with his
friends I'd watch him smoke weed I'd
watch him do Coke I'd watch him drink
every every picture you see of me as a
child someone's holding me with a
Budweiser smoking a cigarette or a joint
you know
um I remember him and my mother playing
tug ofar with me a few times one would
grab my right arm and left arm and pull
me and it was it was pretty abusive you
know and finally when my father
left
um I I cling to my grandfather cuz that
was the next man in my family but
throughout the years I yearned for my
father I wanted a father I wanted to
play catch I never got to play catch
with a with anybody with a football or a
baseball or anything it was all about
work work work work work work work work
work you know in school and
um
so
pretty much I was raised by my
grandfather and when I was with my
mother she was young you know she had me
when she was when she was
20 yeah she had me when she was 20 and
uh
so back at that time our part of the
family was poor me my mother and I and
but my other side of the family um you
could kind
of compare them to the mafia they the
the familyes ran like the mafia kind of
um it was ran by my uncle he's passed
away now his name's Tom C Dyke I will
give that name because that's a very
important name in my family he was one
of my one of the people that I looked up
to the most how he handled the family
and handled the money and everything so
um you know I lived in the on the
streets with my mother we lived in our
cars sometimes we would move house to
house to house I can't even tell you how
many times that I moved and we would
live in the crappiest Apartments we
would live in the car we would live
wherever we could we would live at my
grand grandmother's house
um so we finally moved into his to this
apartment in
Lakeside
and I'll never forget I was riding my
bike and I rode my bike in the garage
and my mom must had shut the garage door
and it closed on my forehead head and
knocked me out got a concussion had to
go to the hospital if you look closely
there's still a scar in my head from it
that that's that was when I was like s
years old 8 years old and
uh so we started living at that
apartment um my mother met this man
named Jim which is my a stepfather today
still is
um and I remember I remember things back
before that when I was a kid there was a
lot of Witchcraft in my family um one of
my aunts practiced dark santoria and we
lived at her house a lot that was when
my dad was still with us so I saw a lot
of things I saw a lot of weird things
that are is hard to explain you know I
would see her her witchcraft stuff set
up and I would see I would see things in
the windows at night I would see I would
see demons if you want to call them
demons I would see figures and I was
just a k did M that and we had pet goats
you know we had pet goats and I had tied
them up one night I think we had six of
them and they were tied to a tree and I
woke up one morning and they were all
slaughtered
everything they were all their insides
were taken out and just Their Skin and
Bones were left and we looked around I
remember we looked around for Footprints
we didn't see nothing there was no sign
of struggle nothing so anyways my my
mother decided since all that stuff was
happening there she she decided to move
us out and that's when we moved to my
grandma's and then when we moved to the
apartment and my father left and my
mother met this man named Jim
well uh about a year or two
later my stepfather goes into the
7-Eleven and gets a quick pick and he
gets it one minute before they cut off
the time for the lottery right and they
won the lottery he won the lottery he
won $5.6 million in the lottery so I go
from go from living in cars to living in
Logan Heights and the bario and you know
uh at everybody's house couch surfing
with my mom and this and that to all of
a sudden we have a nice house you know
we have nice
cars um and that went on till
about uh I was 14 years old but in the
meantime I had gone to a junior high
school and uh my eighth grade year at
the beginning of my eighth grade year I
got on the bus and I remember this uh
Hispanic kid getting on the bus
and he had showed he had flashed a gun
to
me and uh I said I that's weird why
would this kid be flashing a gun to me
so we get to school that
day and uh I had to go to the bathroom I
was I was in my uh
my uh math class and I remember my
teacher Mrs vivada I said I raised my
hand I said could I please use a
restroom and she said yeah I go to the
restroom I went to the
restroom um and and I'm taking a pee in
the ynal and I noticed someone walked in
and I saw the
reflection of that kid that flashed me
the gun in the bus come in the bathroom
and I saw him pull out the gun so I just
started act like I'm peeing soon as he
got up close to me I turned around and
grabbed the gun out of his hand and
Pistol whipped him with it and knocked
him out on the ground and got on top of
him and started to beat him and of
course the principal walks in so it
looks like I had the gun and I was
beating this
guy we ended up both getting expelled
but they both ended up finding out the
truth and to this day no one knows why
that uh this guy brought a gun to kill
me with right um so in junior high you
know now we have a little bit of money
my
mother and stepfather have money
um I started dating this girl I dated a
Playboy model I'm I can't say her name
um she was she was I think April
of centerold for April of 99 I
think or
98 her last name her first name is Julia
that's all I'll say and I dated a girl
named Rose and I think that he was mad
at me because I was dating a Hispanic
woman I I have no idea what his deal was
but uh that point changed my life I
think
forever
um the first time I smoked weed is I
went to a
party at the beginning of the eth grade
year right before that had happened and
I grew up with a lot of uh known people
I I grew up with a guy that drives at
number 48 NASCAR I'm sure you know who
that is his brother was one of my best
friends and he's the one that gave me my
first joint and I remember what shirt he
has on he he was wearing a Metallica he
was wearing a Metallica Kill Them All
shirt I'll never forget it to this day
um I remember his face handed me the
joint and I took a hit and you know what
after that joint that was about it for
drugs for a while you know I ended up
getting spell from school um my mother
got me a homeschool teacher and my
homeschool teacher was a uh he was a
guitar instructor so we really didn't do
any school I learn how to play guitar he
taught me music he taught me how to read
music he taught me how you know and you
know my favorite band back then was Guns
and Roses Penny wise and NWA you know so
I had Rock I had punk rock and some
rap so he ended up teaching me the blues
and I loved it it took a lot of a lot of
the lot of the
uh the hurt I had from being molested
when I was younger I was molested when I
was young at about 6 years old by a
little a friend of mine that was older
than me and then after my parents won
the lottery I got molested again and no
one knew about it and I didn't talk
about that till I worked at a
rehab when I was 33 years old in front
of a bunch of guys so I kept it secret
that whole time so anyways after after
my uh mother and father got the money we
had a lot of nice Christmases you know I
can't complain it was cool it was weird
it was different for me you know um
but the kicker is we ended up going to
Vegas a lot so there was there was about
four or five years where I grew up in
Vegas we stayed in Vegas for months at a
time 3 to four months at a time soon as
the Mirage got built you know my mom
made friends with Steve wi the owner of
a bunch of hotel in Casino is now she's
still friends with them to this day and
uh so they would give me a hundred bucks
and stick me in an arcade by
myself and
uh I would sit there all day and you
know once I got bored of the arcade I I
walk down the strip I walk over to
Caesar palace CU there was magic shops I
loved magic I Lov I loved magicians I
loved card tricks I loved cards I loved
to play cards um
so I learned how to walk the streets of
Vegas and and learned all the hustles
and stuff um by by watching magic I I
learned slide a hand so I would walk by
blackjack tables or poker tables and
grab $100 chips and no one and back then
they didn't have the the security
systems like they do now you know so no
one ever really caught me and I'd always
give my grandpa the chips and where'd
you get those well don't worry better
just just go cash him in you know um I
laugh cuz I think back it's pretty funny
now you know they were teaching me they
were teaching me how to be a hustler
here's 100 bucks while we go and do what
we do in Vegas and we would do this for
months three four months out of every
year um so I grew to uh to live by
myself kind of on my own I was basically
a lashy kid when it came down to it um
during the Summers we would go up to uh
Auburn there there's a place up by
Auburn Way in the Hills where my
grandfather and my uncle worked they
built dams and um did all this stuff up
there for the company and uh I remember
just being a little guy and my
grandfather would give me a gun he'd
give me a 22 uh long barrel a knife and
a fishing pole and I'd walk in that
Forest by myself every day he teached me
how to hunt by myself he would teach me
how to how to how to butcher how to skin
things how to clean the fish how to do
all this stuff
and he had uh how many brothers he had
one two three four he had five brothers
the one brother was a butcher so they
taught me at a young age how to butcher
cattle how to butcher pigs how to you
know how to make our own meat
um but growing up I remember I was
always by myself you know so when I
started
school it was hard for me to fit in cuz
I was by myself I didn't know how to
interact with other kids you know know
um so I always was trying to be somebody
that I really wasn't you know um I was
really smart I never had to study for
any tests I never had to do anything to
pass school I just passed because I knew
I could take I could take the test
and Ace the test no problem and
everybody like what the heck you don't
study you don't do your homework you
don't do nothing I said I don't know so
then when I got in high school my mother
since they had the money
put me into a uh a Christian school I
went to Christian high in
elone uh Dr Jeremiah shout of Mountain
church it's big church down there and so
I got a background in in the the Judea
Judea
Christian religion which I hated right
off the bat I fought it I fought it
right off the bat you know I'd go in
these Bible classes and and listen to
this guy preach on what he thought was
the right doctrine of the Bible and I
always called him out on I said no
that's not what that says and that's not
what that means man why are you teaching
us this so the more I did that the more
they started catching on to me so my I
ended up in the principal's
office with my desk in there and that's
where I stayed all four years so I could
play football so during High School I
didn't do any drugs no drinking nothing
my my uh Outlet was uh sports right
and my freshman year my grandfather had
died I was 14 and that devastated me it
devastated my whole family it it ruined
my mother's life it ruined my life to a
point
um but right before that we went on a a
trip we went all around the country
probably to every state I think we
missed three or four states but I got to
spent some time with him and he actually
took me to see my father no one else
wanted to take me to see my father at
this time my father got
banished from um San Diego his father my
other grandfather my white grandfather
was a bank robbery cop undercover so he
caught my father stealing a bunch of
stuff from stores and and Banks I hear
Banks but I don't know if I believe that
so instead of the judge putting him in
prison he told my grandfather that he
could be banished from California for so
many years I think it was 7 to 10 years
something like that so before my
grandfather had passed away he made me a
promise that he would take me to see my
dad and he did we went and saw my dad in
Virginia and
uh um we got back from that trip and my
grandfather ended up passing away and uh
they he had therosis of the liver so bad
his liver by the time we got him down we
tried to get him shark treatment down in
uh Rosarito or in anada and uh his liver
was the size of a dime so there wasn't
much they could do anymore and I'll
never forget the day that he passed away
I was sitting in there by by myself with
him and he looked at me and he said
Frankie you see those doves up there and
I said no and he goes those are angels
are coming to get me I said okay
whatever you say so we left that night
got home I I hear a scream about I think
it was 2:00 in the morning and it was
was my mother
screaming I ran in there and she goes
Grand grandpa passed away and I remember
just my whole
world sink you know that was my whole
world that was that was who I looked at
as a dad that's who I looked at it
taught me how to how to how to be a man
right
um so after that I was pretty much
raised by my grandmother sometimes my
mother you know but I I missed my
grandpa I missed that
um so I ended up uh getting a lot of
letters for or scholarships for
football and uh I was I was a good
athlete um I was wide receiver and a um
a free
safety and I turned those down because I
knew how to work you know I knew how to
make money and I had a job I was making
I think 15 to 1,700 bucks a week at 17
years old so why do I need to go to
college you know um I was already
hustling I knew how to hustle you know I
knew how to hustle I was raised a
hustler my mom my mother was a hustler
you know
um so what I ended up doing
was I went and signed up for the seals
for the Navy Seals um with a couple of
friends and I ended up backing out and
those same two friends are Navy Seals
today and I still talk to one of them
and I always think man I should have
done that but you know what could have
would have should have I'm right here
because I'm supposed to be right here
you know so it's about that time when I
started partying I think I was 17 and a
half I graduated early cuz I was
young um I graduated with honors so I
could have went to any college I wanted
to but I chose to work
so all that cash I was getting I was so
young I was making so much money I was
the one that had the the half kilo of
coke I was the one that had whatever you
wanted let's have fun let's go to the
desert let's go to the river let's go
let's party so we started partying and
drinking and and you know what my mom at
this time I I was just starting to move
out of my mother's house they built a
huge mansion from the lottery money and
my let me backtrack a little bit my
mother opened a jewelry store helped a
lot of our family bought them house some
houses bought them cars opened a
business the jewelry store so she could
uh help the family that needed work so
they started working for her um that
ended up being a wash it ended up
closing down a few years later
um so during football back in high
school I broke like broke my leg which I
started doing Obi they gave me pills um
I didn't know it at this time but I
started getting addicted to that stuff
and my mother even told me she came she
goes Frank you're going to have a long
road in life you're going to battle
addiction like your father did and I
never really listened to her so anyways
go forward
um uh she ended up gambling most of the
money away
allegedly so we were back to having
nothing so then my mother started
um
I don't want to incriminate my mother
because she's still in the system but
she did some things to to me and my wife
at the time now I'm married me and my
wife at the time she she borrowed some
money and never gave it back which kind
of ruined my marriage
um and she did some things where she got
caught some years later and got put in
prison for it um she just got out and I
don't blame her for that she kept food
on the table for my half sisters or I
don't call them my half sisters they're
my sisters she had to do what she had to
do but on the other hand now I was
caught up in heroin I was I was doing
crystal meth I did meth since I started
doing meth at 17 18 years old
um and I did it for up until last year
you
know um the heroin and the oxyc Hons
only lasted till about
2012 um you know I've had long-term
sobriety I've had seven
years um I went and learned learned
about the addiction and and understood
that the
addiction my
addiction the drugs and alcohol weren't
the problem that was the solution to my
problem you know I took a lot of
psychology classes I took a lot of
classes to get my KAC so I could be a
counselor and in rehabs and and I did I
worked at a couple rehabs um but then my
mental illness started getting
predominant and I started noticing it um
so finally my second wife took me in and
they diagnosed me with paranoid
schizophrenia they diagnosed me with
bipolar disorder they they said you're
on the spectrum they said they didn't
know what I had they said I probably
have Aspergers because I'm very good
with numbers I can see numbers and tell
you what they are um
but in the
meantime we grew up with a we grew up
with a lot of Hell's Angels a lot of
peckerwoods you know we grew they were
they were kind of like our family they
were always around so the first the
second rehab that I went to the first
one I went to was just for alcoholism
the second one was for heroin addiction
and my mother took me there to a place
to eat for my birthday and then she was
going to take me to rehab so I went in
the bathroom to take a pee and a patched
Angel grabs me and goes Frank he hugs me
holds me I'll never forget it held me as
TI as he could he goes Frank stay alive
man stay alive and I didn't understand
and I came out of the bathroom I said
Mom did you set that up and she just
looked at me and
smiled and that didn't happen once that
happened three times now they were they
were upset at me for using heroin
because they knew heroin was going to
kill me right
um they didn't say much about the meth
but ultimately what the meth did was
kicked off the the uh the diseases I
already had and it turned to paranoid
schizophrenia right I'm sure you hear a
lot of those stories
um
um so it's a it's
a
it's almost like it was set up for me
perfectly to go get help to get off
heroin so I went up to this place pelar
Mountain after I've been to rehab many
times and many detoxes I've been to
rehab 19 times in my life um spent
millions of
dollars million hundreds of thousands of
dollars in cash then millions of dollars
obviously in in a um insurance money but
the the two that actually helped or the
three that actually helped were were uh
Palomar Mountain called sober Ranch
Genesis recovery which is down by where
I live and uh alter alter group up here
in Orange
County
um but I'll never forget I was working I
worked for the power companies I was
working and this guy came up to me and
he he was a Mongol and I knew he was a
Mongol and he was always a a jerk to me
and and he had told me something about
say hi to your mom I miss having sex
with her right and I looked at him and
I'm older now you know and I said I
wouldn't say that if I was
you two months later that guy's dead you
know I can't explain it I don't know
what happened he he's dead he was dead
showed up dead they said he drove his
bike off a bridge and there's a lot of
things like that that has happened in my
life that are unexplainable
that almost like it's all been set up
I've always been kept safe by somebody
you know
um now I've been arrested many times
been to jail many times now when I get
arrested or if I get arrested God forbid
I do anymore they don't they don't take
me to jail they have to take me to the
psych because of what I'm diagnosed with
um
so what what I wanted to come talk to
you about is is the mental illness you
know drugs are the solution to the
mental illness and how we were brought
up and raised um I cover I try to fill
that darkness and that void with the
drugs and alcohol or whatever it is it
could be more than it could be working
out too much it could be you know
whatever
um I just want people to be
aware that it is that is it's just a
solution man that's not the problem we
have to talk to somebody and we have
have to let people
know
that what the government's doing out
here is not right I mean fentanyl's
killing people they don't even bring up
ketamine which ketamine's killing a lot
of people too
um you know I've spent a lot of time on
the streets I lived on the streets for
years um I watched people get murdered
for a $10 sack of heroin you know I've
seen so many things that that kids
shouldn't seen and
uh I'm thankful to be alive today you
know you know I've done I've done a lot
of lot of things that I regret but do I
really regret them no it made me it's
made me the man I am today it's made me
be able to talk about it it's made me be
able to talk about my M molestations to
other men that have the same problem
that need to hear somebody talk about it
um does it haunt me every day hell yes
it haunts me every day every day of my
life it haunts me I wake up you
know people talk about triggers what
triggers you see you learn all this
stuff all these rehabs you go to you
what triggers you you know what I'm
triggered when I open my damn eyes in
the morning right that's when I'm
triggered you know and I I I heard
someone say one
time I heard someone say one time that
uh
um it's not it's just business it's just
business it's not pleasure you know know
it's just a business of the
game
um but I honestly the more of us that
talk about this kind of stuff the more
we're going to shed light on the
darkness that they don't want us to talk
about and you know who they are so you
know you know I watched the skid R stuff
you know we got skid ow in San Diego
just like La it's getting just as bad
you know and my favorite thing to do is
to go on them streets I I give my last
dollar to someone because you know what
they did it for me you know I'll go buy
a guy a beer because he did it for me
you know so my agenda in life is to is
to help others like
me just like your agenda you know um I
think it's important that we that we
speak out
against against all the BS that we're
taught and that they show us on TV and
that they tell
it's all Bs man you know I grew up I
grew up with a lot of cartel members and
I'll tell you what some of them are the
nicest people you'll ever meet honest to
God some Hell's Angels are the nicest
people you'll ever meet in your life and
they help so many people that no one
ever gives them the benefit of the doubt
because the stigma surrounding them
right just like the people on the
streets probably the most smartest
intelligent people you'll ever meet live
on those streets you know and people
don't give them a chance and that's why
they don't want nothing to do with this
BS they don't want to pay the taxes to a
uh a government that isn't even a
government or a US entity right screw
them why do that when they're not
letting us speak
out I want to shed light on the darkness
of this of this
world um I want to do the best I can to
keep the fentanyl to keep ketamine to
keep all the drugs that kill off the
streets
um I understand that that some of us
need certain certain things to stay
alive but we've been programmed that way
and we need to re re reprogram ourselves
you know we need to reprogram ourselves
and see the light and quit looking at
that Darkness because there is a light
man there is a light and I'll do
whatever I can to help change this world
so uh thanks for listening all right
Frank thank you so
much